this may be the best unboxing we have
ever done at geek culture right here
we've got the haslab proton pack in the
house you can only give us some
crowdfunding sources or if you know
somebody at a collector's store but
we've got it right here plus we've got
hasbros you're trying to WAND as well to
go along with this I am pumped Zach are
you ready for this oh yeah
yeah let's do this bad boy come on okay
this box is oh this is heavy man
what is this spot 16 kg 20 kg if you're
getting this this is what to expect and
I think the cardboard box is even bigger
this is massive now of course looks like
a chest we've got the warning stickers
on it the Ghostbuster logo it's
weathered they're saying this is a
screen copy one-to-one replica what
we're seeing from Ghostbusters and of
course it's gonna be modeled after the
84 and the 2021 afterlife movie
foreign this is awesome let's do this
okay
open up the box here real quick
oh this is cool check this out
let me see if I took that for you guys
you see that right there that is
actually the wood underneath spangler's
chair remember at his old house where he
was
he was killed and he put things
underneath the trap door slide it open
and look what pops up
like the trap door underneath the chair
very very cool it's a nice afterlife
references in here now we've got in this
kit we've got the little mini
marshmallow men as well as of course the
proton pack and we've got the hoses now
we didn't get the Slime because that is
when you know part of the I think first
year of the crowdfunding but nonetheless
we've got all pretty much everything we
need here let's open up this here real
quick it's called the fantasmical
samples
Handle With Care
in the white box
then we also got this box here as well
looks like a ghost trap but this is
where the marshmallow men are inside let
me just close this up here real quick
and we're going to do this one by one oh
man the packaging on this is absolutely
awesome look at this real quick take a
look at the packaging
the details the weatherness looks like
metal but it's actually paper you know
Rico friendly here now we're going to
cut open the tape here with our trusty
GC knife we've got
oh the mini steep up marshmallow man
look at this one look how cool this is
his belly's burnt exactly that looks
like you're at the beach
this one on the side
this is crazy I love the detail on this
this is this is fantastic in terms of
the feel it's very solid this feels like
a really nice
you can turn the arms a little bit but I
don't want to turn them too much because
they should be like that and they do
stand really well on the table I think
each of them are burnt in a different
way
[Applause]
this one's burn on his left side here
very cute right now what I'm seeing this
box may be just totally worth it just
based on this alone this is awesome
okay now looks like we have bits and
pieces of marshmallow in here maybe you
can do head swaps on this look at that
look at the expression on this they did
an amazing job on this this is hilarious
absolutely loving it Abby it looks like
you when you're pissed off
we call that baby Abby right there all
right now we're gonna open up the
fantasmical samples as well
oh okay what do we got what do we got
what the hell
[Applause]
what is this I'm gonna marshmallow fluff
the melted marshmallow fluff marshmallow
mixed with ectoplasm
oh it's marshmallow fluff just don't
wear this on your jeans guys it'll look
wrong you put this on the proton pack
and it looks like Marshmallow with
plasma or something yeah anyway it's
kind of like white color to it as you
can see there's holes here and there's
little knobs here for attachments
yeah you could just do oh yeah
that just looks wrong in many ways
you've watched the wrong Ghostbusters
movie Zaki let's open this up and let's
continue on what is inside ah
maybe we have all our answers right here
because there might be an instruction
manual ah okay cool we've got a
blueprint on how the neutron of wand
[Applause]
and the proton pack how you can display
it how you can connect it up all that is
here I love the writing on this it looks
very handwritten hand-drawn very very
cool
oh this looks complex oh man I need
batteries on this we need four DLR 20
1.5 volt batteries to this which you
have to have a screwdriver with so we
will look for those batteries we'll have
them on standby but we're going to get
to that in just a second all right we're
moving along got something else in there
this is fun the way they do this
unboxing is really cool like this is a
bit of a maze and a journey
we've got some cool stuff inside don't
know what is what
this is really really neat okay
oh
this is awesome
dude
this is better than any of the
lightsabers they've done before
oh my God the detail
holy this is badass
oh man I think I need to get one of
these wow this is legit oh dude let me
just explain
how awesome this is
seriously we unbox a lot of cool
Collectibles here we've unboxed almost
all the lightsabers from Hasbro Hasbro
pulse and all that stuff and some of
them are really cool right the darksaber
Etc
this beats them all
I get why
this is at its price point and why this
is going to be so sought after dude this
is insane
before I show you this though if you're
looking for the best laptop in town you
know you're gonna call MSI meet the
summit e16 flip featuring the latest
11th gen Intel Core i7 processor RTX 30
series graphics and a 16 inch QHD plus
touchscreen panel with a 360 degree
hinge better yet it lets you unleash
maximum productivity with up to 11 hours
of battery life at just 2 kilograms the
summit e16 flip offers unprecedented
performance and functionality allowing
you to work and play anywhere and
anytime we're back
and let's show you what the proton pack
looks like okay this is Hefty so for you
guys that want to see the details on
this it is absolutely mind-blowing I
mean from the hoses to the metal knobs
here we got a little bit of plastic we
can take it off right there just to sort
of protect that area this is really
really cool
what an amazing job Hasbro's done with
this thing I mean this is freaking
phenomenal even let's say
this ribbon here this data ribbon here
oh man the different materials they're
using the weatherness of it all and it
feels solid so what's cool on this as
well is you can actually take all this
off and go inside the proton pack
remember when Phoebe was doing this an
afterlife and spanglers ghost was
helping her fix this and repair it well
you could do the same thing with this as
well now let's look to the back of it
man
talk about okay we got some legitimate
padding right here this feels like
military surplus grade right now this
back is hard this is not going to be
comfortable we've got the door here
where you put your batteries in but
you've got this padding at the bottom
here by your lower back so that's going
to protect the lower back then of course
we've got a strap that goes around the
waist because this is going to be pretty
hefty we'll take that off real quick so
you can actually see the Buckle
non-glamorous unwrapping on that but
that's just going to show you what the
Buckle looks like there so you can just
unclip that and it goes around your
waist and the straps are adjustable as
well so no matter what your size is if
you're a more prosperous individual or
if you are a leaner individual
this proton pack will fit you now we're
going to put the nutritional one on this
and show you how it's down here because
if you actually got the Hasbro Neutron
one because that's the one that goes
along with this and that came out a
couple years ago it slides in here and
that bracket is actually on the one
itself you'll see that right there as
well so let's actually do that right now
here's the nutrona wand by Hasbro
absolutely love this by the way
there's this bracket here that goes onto
the proton pack so they were thinking of
this whole entire thing years ago but
why did it take Hasbro so long
because they knew afterlife was coming
they were waiting for the right time and
today is the right time for this okay so
all you do is you take this metal
bracket you match it to this try this
bracket here
and you slide it down and there you go
that is the proton pack in all its Glory
but you probably think about Bobby
wasn't there a hose that connected to
the back of the nocturnal wand into the
proton pack you're right
we actually have the hose with us as
well it's in one of the boxes in the
main box itself do you know you need a
large hose for your proton pack always
everything also what else we have inside
of here this is one of the seriously one
of the best unboxings
we've done from Hasbro at least for me
at least oh
it's a metal rod with something else on
it it could be a radio thing
that's the name of it radio thing
hello so this piece here goes ah goes
here
just push down another push too hard
there it is now we've got Wi-Fi we've
got Wi-Fi baby we've got an orange cap
for safety reasons obviously as you're
walking around because you don't want to
like get into a situation
it's for safety reasons that's what that
orange cap is for probably in America
you always walk around with this on the
streets you want to be safe put a little
orange cap on it okay this is becoming
an Ikea project real quick here
Suzuki got all these kind of things
what's the Swedish name for proton pack
I think it's not glass
yes that's our name that's our Swedish
name for the proton pack so you employ
let's just take this thing off first
this is cool take this off
so you take out the battery pack
I'm going to slide this in here
that's connected then we connect it to
the bottom we're gonna put this in here
ah there we go look at that hooking up
hoses and screwing things in that's my
forte
ah there we go
so this is the proton pack
with the hose attached this is wicked
man this is cool now of course we've got
to put batteries inside of this to power
everything on because I believe this
proton pack now will power on the
neutron one before we had to have extra
batteries to do that
but now this should take care of
everything so when I have my Screwdriver
from Zacky here and I'm not going to say
anything about his very long screwdriver
we have for this but we are going to
unscrew the door so we can place the
batteries inside of this I'm going to
show you what batteries you need to as
well all right so we got the batteries
here and we've got four of them so these
are the batteries you're going to need
here real quick these are the size you
need for these These are 1.5 volt r20p
heavy duty batteries it's a lot of juice
it needs for this thing man
I haven't used a battery like this in
years
these are the batteries used to get as a
kid when we power up our toys
now everything is like
[Music]
already making sounds when you put all
the batteries in it means it works
startup sound but actually it's cool
because that way you know the batteries
are placed incorrectly when you hear
that sound
Hauser was thinking in these things
we got the batteries in ah
and we are getting the stand put
together as we speak we'll show you how
that works as well the power button is
hahaha
[Applause]
[Music]
this is insane
holy
the whole thing's going on wow dude
holy this is badass this is the
best thing Hasbro's ever made
holy cow
hahaha
oh
it turned off
so yeah thanks Jackie
that makes life easier so in terms of
Stan the build quality on this feels a
little bit less than the proton pack
which is a bit unfortunate so if you're
looking for a really cool display stand
I'm sure somebody will make something
that is equal to the build quality of
the proton back but this just feels a
little bit like an afterthought
um but yeah the screws we didn't figure
out the screws and the mounting brackets
are for the back of the proton pack to
mount that as well so that's something
different that we don't have with us
here today now there's two modes as I
mentioned earlier there's the 84 mode
and the afterlife mode now to get to
these modes you actually can't flip a
switch on the outside of this proton
pack you have to go inside of it which
is kind of cool in a way because they've
actually designed the inner workings as
we saw in afterlife when Phoebe as I
mentioned was working with her
grandfather Spangler to sort of rebuild
these proton packs so to do that you
have to unscrew this portion here
is a Long Rod will come out with this to
the side this bracket will slide out
right here and this will also come out
as well this bracket comes off and
there's grooves on the side for that now
here's where it gets tricky because
you have to hold this here and I believe
you probably could take these off I
don't know we're just kind of doing a
quick quicker version of this and then
you're just going to
screw this portion here and we're
already seeing the inner workings of the
proton back but right here are the
switches these are the switches for the
motor to turn on and off in terms of
vibration and the afterlife sounds up is
afterlife down is classic for this
switch right here for the motor for that
vibration Up is on down is off so it'd
be cool if you can actually do that on
the outside of the pack but I guess for
you know authenticity reasons and to
make it you know give you a little more
fun to kind of dive into this a bit more
they have it set up that way now you
take this piece off here and you
actually pull this out and then you see
the inner workings like the microchips
and all that sort of the conductors
inside of here that's what this is all
set up like and then just put that back
on slide this this is quite heavy by the
way
put this knob here
then we put this portion now with cool
if you want to test the sounds you just
have to have these connectors touch here
on these connectors that way you can
actually hear what the sounds are like
so case in point
this is the afterlife sound
and you can feel the vibration you have
your volume knob here you can go louder
or
you can go quieter but you hear the
vibrations that's the motor on
[Music]
it's about the highest it goes it's loud
but it's not overly loud okay we're
gonna turn that off
remove this
now we're going to go into classic Mode
you hear that sound for authentication
and
now we're gonna try this
so it's quieter case in point 84 not as
many sound effects
2021 they can do a little bit more
yeah because the motor on this is slower
the lights are slower here on the 84 on
the afterlife they're much faster they
cycle through much faster the lights
here about the same on the side of the
proton pack so uh yeah and the vibration
is there now if I want to
[Music]
turn that off we'll see what like
without the motor on
84 sound motor off
so you do get to hear a little bit more
of it
um in terms of the the humming and
everything else without the motor of
course because it's not as strong
nice
let's go to afterlife sound
you are going to get a lot more salads
at the afterlife version of it and the
lights and everything else like that but
I mean if you want to be authentic of
course 84 I personally like this better
than the 84 just sounds more
there's more depth to it yeah it's a
nice word for that there's more depth
exactly depth with a proton pack that's
it okay so we're gonna put this all back
together and then uh we'll share what
else is inside this bad boy
okay so just walking through some of
this real quick here now this is very
intricate all pretty much screen
accurate I don't know all the names of
everything so I'm referring to a Reddit
image here that's going to help me
through this so we'll walk through some
of the features we've got this ribbon
cable here which does a really cool
feature where it actually will kind of
short-circuit it by a sound so if we
turn this on
you could actually you have to push
these knobs in and take this off
[Music]
so you get that sort of like a short
circuiting and it's powering down
that's it then of course you want to put
these back on
it's not the easiest thing to get on
there we go just kind of squeeze that uh
the buttons in and then it locks in and
then you're good to go
that's one thing
now turning it around on its side here
so you can see this
we've got the power cell now the power
cell unfortunately there's nothing in it
because
you're powered by batteries but I did
find a very good usage for it
you need a wallet you need your wallet
on you
in your jumpsuit on top buckets exactly
pop your wallet in
now you have your wallet and your proton
pack if you're wondering what size
wallet well I have a standard LV wallet
there
and then there you go you need to pay
for a drink get on the bus
you're Waltzing your proton pack yeah so
this is the booster right here uh here
real quick and obviously it's not as
weathered as some images online but it
still looks cool nonetheless you
probably can weather a little bit if you
know how to do that with paint but we're
going to keep it as is because we just
actually like the whole look at this
entire thing
um we've got the crank generator here
now there is a switch underneath here
and we have no idea what the switch is I
think it's just there for show because
nothing in the instruction manual so
it's a little bit tricky now inside of
this cyclotron right here there's
actually some really cool bits and
pieces we don't know the exact names of
them but they don't really do anything
but they just kind of this is a little
bit like more just for authenticity like
they look like little like transistors
that you can unscrew and screw back in
sort of help power it but they have no
effect on the lights whatsoever the
lights are actually built into this and
you can't change that but it's just
another nice effect that Hasbro did to
sort of uh give the fans much more
detail to a proton pack than we normally
see from a consumer retail version such
as this I mean they really outdone
themselves in that regard now what's
very cool about this is actually you can
control this entire proton back from
your Neutron a wand it's all ready to go
then if we
[Music]
it turns off the proton pack so you
don't need to hit this switch all the
time to turn the proton pack on and off
especially if you have the neutron to
want if you don't have the neutron of
one then you have to do that but again
you probably want to get this
if you get this so now that we've got
that covered we're going to show you
what else is inside the box here and
actually some paperwork so we got these
1980 stickers here that if you want to
stick it on somewhere you can it's kind
of cool you know because back in the 80s
they always have these fun things we got
spangler's Journal which is quite
detailed in terms of writings and stuff
like that it's all inside there pictures
of his family
et cetera et cetera et cetera we got
more stickers covering afterlife
so kind of bring the 84 Vibe into 2021
and then if you have the 84 pack now
there's various different packs when you
uh got this on the ground crowdfunding
you can actually get uh more of a newer
look and then that's where these
stickers come into play so if I want to
replace these stickers with this to get
the 84 fresh look
then you could do it with this but
honestly speaking
the weathering the details the way it
looks I wouldn't even touch this thing I
would not add another sticker on it I
mean you maybe want to weather this but
you don't have to outside of that it is
freaking amazing
so
you know what that means Jackie we got a
proton pack here we got a neutron of
wand it's time to suit up and fight some
ghosts
[Music]
this place is creepy
so
Impressions wearing this thing it's
heavy man this is very very heavy I tell
you what if you are a smaller person
who's not that strong you're going to
feel this in a bit because there's
really no padding on the back of it so
it's just hard class of course you have
padding right here at the lower back
which isn't so bad
but yeah you're gonna
I think after about 10-15 minutes you're
gonna be like all right I'm done with
this but it's badass this is really
catching up no it's not age man this is
called weight it's heavy anyway let's go
uh go catch some ghosts
I'll go
hey yeah
I don't think he figured that one out
do you guys see ghosts
any ghost
no ghost excuse me sorry have you seen
ghosts also you're right okay okay okay
okay okay
hi uh we got a call around here some
disturbance was there a ghost or
something or no
Ghostbuster no okay all right I'll look
out
there's good there's always ghosts in
hotels let's go
[Music]
hi
I'm we got a call was there a
disturbance here some sort of
like some sort of demons or ghosts
I'm on Ghostbuster any sort of demons or
ghosts upstairs
you sure
I'll check the perimeter what's going on
hello hey
hey I hear you guys got some ghosts
inside Ghostbuster you got ghosts inside
I don't have a ghost you sure yeah no
problem you want me to go check no
problem I'll go check I'll go check
let's go Jackie
goes right here okay let's go
ghost in here
[Music]
I can't fit in there I can't fit in
there did you see a ghost where was the
ghost at where is the ghost
foreign
[Music]
absolutely love the proton pack by
Hasbro I know this is very limited not a
lot of people are going to get their
hands on it
but
this is amazing
it's heavy
and I'll tell you it's not easy to put
I'm going to turn a wand back on you're
going to need help it's not easy to do
one-handed but to take it off is pretty
good but uh overall
this is for the cosplay players out
there this is for the people they just
want to address and we're going to have
a collectible in their home
this is freaking amazing
man it's not cheap
but it's worth having if you could
afford it now those are my thoughts on
the proton pack and the neutrona one by
Hasbro let me know your thoughts in the
comment section below if you like this
video check out more of our collectible
videos right here